you've talked about quantifying your
thinking
we've been talking about this sort of
game theoretic view on life
and putting probabilities behind
estimates like if you think about
different trajectories you can take
through life just actually analyzing
life in a game theoretic way like your
own life like personal life you i think
you've given an example
that you had an honest conversation with
igor about like how long is this
relationship gonna last
so similar to our sort of marriage
problem kind of discussion
having an honest conversation about the
probability
of things that we sometimes are a little
bit too shy or scared to think of in
probabilistic terms
can you speak to that kind of way of
reasoning uh the good and the bad of
that
can you do this kind of thing with human
relations
yeah so the
the scenario you're talking about it was
like yeah tell me about that yeah uh
i think he was about a year into our
relationship
um and we were
having a fairly heavy conversation
because we were trying to figure out
whether or not i was going to sell my
apartment well you know
he had already moved in but i think we
were just figuring out what like our
long-term plans would be should we
should we buy a place together et cetera
well you guys are having that
conversation are you like drunk out of
your mind on wine or is he sober and
you're actually having a serious like
how do you get to that conversation
because most people are kind of afraid
to have that kind of serious
conversation
well
so you know our relationship was very
well first of all we were good friends
for a couple of years before we even you
know got you know romantic
um
and
when we did get romantic it was very
clear that this was a big deal it wasn't
just like another like you know it
wasn't a random thing
um and so the probability of it being a
big deal was high was already very high
and then we'd been together for a year
and it had been pretty golden and
wonderful so you know
there was a lot of foundation already
where we felt very comfortable having a
lot of frank conversations but igor's
mo has always been much more than mine
he was always from the outset like just
in a relationship
radical transparency and honesty is the
way because the truth is the truth
whether you want to hide it or not you
know but it will come out eventually and
um
if you aren't able to accept difficult
things yourself then how could you
possibly expect to be like the most
integral version that you know you can't
the relationship needs this bedrock of
like honesty as a foundation more than
anything yeah that's really interesting
but i would like to push against some of
those ideas but okay all right but
that's the down the line just throw them
up uh i just rudely interrupt
um and so you know we we've been about
together for a year and things were good
and we were having this hard
conversation
and and then he was like well okay
what's the likelihood that we're going
to be together in three years then
because i think it was roughly a
three-year time horizon
and i was like oh interesting and
everybody actually wait don't before you
said out loud let's both write down our
predictions formally
um because we'd been like we were just
getting into like effective altruism and
rationality at the time which is all
about making you know formal predictions
as a means of uh
measuring your own um
well your your own foresight essentially
in a quantified way
so we like both wrote down our
percentages and we also did a one-year
uh prediction and a 10-year one as well
so we got percentages for all three
and then we showed each other um and i
remember like having this moment of like
oh because after the ten year and i was
like oh well i mean
i love them a lot but like a lot can
happen in ten years you know and
um we've only been together for you know
so i was like i think it's over 50
percent but it's definitely not 90 and i
remember like wrestling i was like oh
but i don't want him to be hurt i don't
want him to you know i don't want to
give a number lower than his and i
remember thinking i was like
don't game it
this is a exercise in radical honesty
so just give you a real percentage and i
think mine was like 75 percent and then
we showed each other and luckily we were
fairly well aligned
um
and
but honestly if we weren't twenty
percent
definitely it definitely would have i
if his had been consistently lower than
mine that would have
rattled me for sure whereas if it had
been the other way around i think he
would he's just kind of like a water off
the duck's back type of guy he'd be like
okay well all right we'll figure this
out well did you guys provide air bars
on the estimate like the level once they
became built in we didn't give formal
plus or minus error bars i didn't draw
any or anything like that i guess that's
the question i have is did you feel
informed enough
to make such decisions because like i
feel like if you were if i were to do
this kind of thing rigorously
i would want some data
uh i would want to say one of the
assumptions you have is you're not that
different from other relationships right
and so
i want to i want to have some data about
the base rates
yeah and and also actual trajectories of
relationships i would love to have
um like time series data
about the ways that relationships fall
apart or prosper
uh how they collide with different life
events
losses job changes moving
uh
both partners find jobs
only one has a job i want that kind of
data and how often the different
trajectories change in life like
how
rep how informative is your past to your
future that's the whole thing like i can
you look at my
life and have a good prediction about in
terms of my characteristics and my
relationships what that's going to look
like in the future or not i don't even
know the answer that question i'll be
very ill informed in terms of making the
probability i would be far
yeah i i just would be under-informed i
would be under-informed i'll be
over-biasing to my prior experiences i
think
right but as long as you're aware of
that and you're honest with yourself i
still and you're honest with the other
person say look i have really wide error
bars on this for the following reasons
that's okay i still think it's better
than not trying to quantify it at all if
you're trying to make really major
irreversible life decisions and i feel
also the romantic nature of that
question for me personally i would
i try to live my life thinking it's very
close to 100 percent
like
allowing myself actually the this is
this is the difficulty of this is
allowing myself to think differently
i feel like has a psychological
consequence that's where that's what's
one of my pushbacks against radical
honesty
is uh this one one particular
perspective so you're saying you would
you would rather give a falsely high
percentage
to your partner going back to uh
in order to survive the traditional
optimism
yes of uh fake it till you make it about
the positive the power possible
well so that and this comes back to this
idea of useful fictions yeah right and i
i agree i don't think there's a clear
answer to this and i think it's actually
quite subjective some people just works
better for than others
um
you know to be clear igor and i weren't
doing this
formal prediction in it like we we did
it with very much tongue-in-cheek
it wasn't like we were gonna make i
don't think it even would have
drastically changed what we decided to
do even we kind of just did it more as a
fun exercise um but the consequence of
that fun exercise you really actually
kind of there was a deep honesty to it
too exactly it was a deep and it was it
was just like this moment of reflection
i'm like oh wow i actually have to think
like through this quite critically and
so on
and
and it's also what was interesting was
like you know i got to like check in
with what what my what my desires were
so there was one thing of like what my
actual prediction is but what are my
desires and could these desires be
affecting my predictions and so on and
you know that's a that's a method of
rationality and i personally don't think
it loses anything in terms of i didn't
take any of the magic away from our
relationship quite the opposite like it
brought us closer together because it
was like we did this weird fun thing um
that i appreciate a lot of people find
quite strange um and i think it was
somewhat you know
unique in our relationship that both of
us are very
you know we both love numbers we both
love statistics we're both poker players
um
so this this was kind of like our safe
space anyway
for others you know one part one partner
like really
might not like that kind of stuff at all
in which cases it's not a good exercise
to do you know i don't recommend it to
everybody um but i do think there's
you know it's interesting sometimes to
poke holes in the or you know
probe at these
things that we consider so sacred that
we can't try to quantify them
but which is interesting because that's
intention with like the idea of what we
just talked about with beauty and like
what makes something beautiful the fact
that you can't measure everything about
it um and perhaps something shouldn't be
tried to make you know maybe it's wrong
to
completely try and value the utilitarian
you know put a utilitarian frame of
measuring the
the utility of a tree in in its entirety
i don't know maybe we should maybe we
shouldn't i'm ambivalent on that but
overall
people have too many biases
people are overly biased against
trying to
do like a quantified cost-benefit
analysis on really tough life decisions
um you know they're like oh just go with
your gut it's like well sure but guts
are our intuitions are best suited for
things that we've got tons of experience
in
then we can really you know trust on it
if it's a decision we've made many times
but if it's like should i marry this
person or should i buy this house over
that house you only make those decisions
a couple of times in your life maybe um
well i would love to know
there's a balance that probably is a
personal balance of strike
is the amount of rationality you you
apply
to a question versus
um
the useful fiction
the
fake it till you make it for example
just talking to soldiers in ukraine
you ask them
what's the probability of
you winning
ukraine winning
um almost everybody i talk to is a
hundred percent
wow
and you listen to the experts right they
they say all kinds of stuff right they
are
they
first of all the morale there is higher
than probably and i've i've never been
to a war zone before this
but i've read about
many wars and i think the morale in
ukraine is higher than almost anywhere
i've read about it's every single person
in the country is proud to fight for
their country
everybody not just soldiers not
everybody why do you think that is
specifically more than you know in other
words
um i think because there's uh perhaps
a dormant desire
for the citizens of this country
to find the identity of this country
because it's been
going through this 30-year process of
different factions and political
bickering
and they haven't had as they talk about
they haven't had their independence war
they say all great nations have had an
independence war they had to fight
for their independence
for the discovery of the identity of the
core of the ideals that unify us and
they haven't had that there's constantly
been factions there's been divisions
there's been pressures from empires from
the united states and from russia from
nato and europe everybody telling them
what to do now they want to discover who
they are and there's that kind of sense
that
we're going to fight for the safety of
our homeland but we're also going to
fight for our identity and that um
on top of the fact that there's just
if you look at the history of ukraine
and there's certain other countries like
this
there are certain cultures are feisty
in their pride
of being part of being the citizens of
that nation ukraine is that
poland was that there's you just look at
history in certain countries you do not
want to occupy right
i mean both stalin and hitler talked
about poland in this way they're like
this is
this is a big problem if we occupy this
land for prolonged periods of time
they're going to be a pain in their ass
like they're not going to be want to be
occupied and certain other countries are
like pragmatic they're like well you
know leaders come and go i guess this is
good you know they're
ukraine just doesn't have ukrainians
those team throughout the 20th century
don't seem to be the kind of people that
just like
sit calmly
and let the quote-unquote occupiers
um in in uh impose their that that's
interesting though because you said it's
you know it's always been under conflict
and leaders have come and gone yeah so
you would expect them to actually be the
opposite under that yeah
because well because they're it's a very
fertile land
it's great for agriculture so a lot of
people want to i mean i think they've
developed this culture because they've
constantly been occupied by different
people for the different peoples
and so
uh
maybe there is something to that where
you've constantly had to
feel
like within the blood of the generations
there's the struggle for
um against the man
against the imposition of uh rules
against oppression and all that kind of
stuff and that stays with them so
there's a there's a will there um but
you know a lot of other aspects are also
part of that that has to do with
the reverse smaller kind of situation
where social media has definitely played
a part of it um also different
charismatic individuals have had to play
a part the fact that uh the president of
the nation zolensky
stayed in kiev during the
the invasion
uh was is a huge inspiration to them
because
most leaders as you can imagine
when the capital of the nation is under
attack
the wise thing the smart thing that the
united states advised the zelinski to do
is to flee and to to be the leader of
the nation from a from a distant place
right he said [ __ ] that i'm staying put
you know everyone around him there was a
pressure to leave
and he didn't and that that
in you know those singular acts
um really can unify a nation there's a
lot of people that criticized the
landscape within ukraine uh before the
war is very unpopular even still
but they put that aside for the
for the especially that singular act of
staying in the capital
yeah
a lot of those kinds of things
come together to to to create something
within people
these things always
of course though like
the you know which
how zoomed out of a view do you want to
take
because yeah you describe it it's like
an anti-moloch thing happened within
ukraine because it brought the ukrainian
people together in order to fight a
common enemy
maybe that's a good thing maybe that's a
bad thing in the end we don't know how
this is all going to play out right
um but if you zoom it out from
the level you know on a global level
they're coming together to you know
fight
that
that could you know that could make a
conflict larger you know what i mean i
don't i don't know what the right answer
is here um yeah it seems like a good
thing that they came together i but i
like we don't know how this is all gonna
play out if this all turns into nuclear
war we'll be like okay that was the bad
that was uh oh yeah so i was describing
the the reverse molec for the local
level exactly now this is where the
experts come in
and they say well
if you uh
channel most of the resources the nation
and the nations supporting
ukraine into the war effort
are you not
beating the drums of war that is much
bigger than ukraine in fact
even the ukrainian leaders are speaking
of it this way this is not a war between
two nations
this is
this is the early days of a world war
if we don't play this correctly yes
uh and they
we need cool heads from our leaders
so you from ukraine's perspective we
need to win ukraine needs to win the war
because what is winning the war mean
is
coming up coming to
peace negotiations an agreement
that guarantees no more invasions and
then you make an agreement about
what land belongs to who right and that
that's you stop that and and
to sh basically
from their perspective is you want to
demonstrate to the rest of the world
who's watching carefully including
russia and china
and different players on the
geopolitical stage that this kind of
conflict is not going to be productive
right if you engage in it so you want to
teach everybody a lesson let's not do
world war three it's not it's gonna be
bad for everybody it's a it's a lose
lose
deep lose lose
doesn't matter
so but they you know um but it and i
think that's actually
a correct
uh when i zoom out
i mean
99 of what i think about is just
individual human beings and human lives
and just that war is horrible
but when you zoom out and think from a
geopolitics perspective we should
realize that
it's entirely possible that we will see
a world war iii in the 21st century
and this is like a dress rehearsal for
that and so the way
we play this
as a as a human civilization will will
define whether we do or don't have a
world war three
um you know
um
how we discuss war
how we discuss nuclear war the kind of
leaders we
we elect and uh prop up the kind of
memes
we circulate because you have to be very
careful when you're being
uh pro-ukraine for example you have to
realize that you're being
um you are also indirectly
feeding
the ever-increasing military-industrial
complex
so be extremely careful
that
when you say pro-ukraine or pro-anybody
your
pro human beings
uh not pro the machine
exactly that uh
that uh creates narratives that says
it's pro-human beings but it's actually
if you look at the raw
use of
funds and resources it's actually probe
making weapons and shooting bullets and
dropping bombs right the real we have to
just
somehow get the meme into everyone's
heads that the real enemies wore itself
that's the enemy we need to defeat
and
that doesn't mean to say that you know
there isn't justification for
small local
scenarios you know adversarial
adversarial conflicts you know if you
have a leader who is starting wars
you know they're on the side of team war
basically it's not that they're on the
side of team country whatever that
country is it's they're on the side of
team war so that needs to be stopped and
put down but you also have to find a way
that your
corrective measure doesn't actually then
end up being co-opted by the war machine
and creating greater war again the
playing field is finite the scale of
in conflict is now getting so big that
you know the weapons that can be used
are so mass destructive
um
that we can't afford another giant
conflict we just we won't make it
you